hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to will you press the
button now we're gonna find out if I'm
actually insane or not and I've already
determined that before I even started
recording all right it doesn't matter
what I say because it's not gonna be as
good as the stuff in front of me right
here okay alright cool so the first one
is you have the ability to tell when
people are lying but you always know
even when it be better to believe the
lie hidden truths false complements
every single well that's just kidding
what you asked for right I mean if you
want to know when people are lying then
they have reasons for lying and some of
those reasons ain't too pretty I mean
people can lie to your face friends lie
right to your face just because they
don't want to hurt your feelings they're
called little white lies now I'm not
saying they're good or bad but I'll take
the ability to tell when people are
lying no matter what because that's
invaluable I mean who cares I mean it's
not like and read their minds I don't
have to ask the question if I didn't
want to know the answer anyway than why
would I ask question in the first place
that's dumb I'll push it what's what's
the downside there yeah that's right
everybody else is with me yeah what's
the downside you would have the power to
turn invisible but you would have your
first child when you are 12 years old
does that mean that I have to give birth
to this child because I don't think 12
year old me would be able to handle that
but then again I'm invisible so I guess
I could just hide that's being
irresponsible but then what 12 year old
would be a responsible parent
oh yeah there's bad either way I don't
think I value the ability to turn
invisible I guess you know you know the
thing is like if you're 12 years old and
you had a kid no one in their right mind
would trust a 12 year old to raise a
child so it's not even like you would
have to raise it a 12 year old is not
ready to be a parent
so either Child Protective Services
would take the child or your parents
would help you out maybe
maybe I'll take the invisibility cuz hey
a superpower is a superpower no matter
what the cost it's all about sacrificing
for the greater good right that's how it
works
that's what pedo parco told me ooh 54:46
not bad oh don't run away Richard you
that's bad even though I suggested that
but I wasn't serious when I suggested it
it wasn't serious all right next you get
the car of your dreams but you have to
sit and stare at it for six months
before you can drive it see I don't
really have a car of my dreams
I've never been a car guy I'm not a
Motorhead I'm not anyone that actually
like reads up into cars I don't know
what Hana Dutton is talking about when
they're saying 67 Chevy Impala I mean I
know it's a 1967 Chevy Impala but I
don't know if that's important or not I
have no idea so this is meaningless to
me so I'd rather not waste my life
sitting and staring at something for six
months no but what why would people
press that that's wasted life that's
wasted life I mean I'm thinking if you
think about this logically I bet that's
a cumulative of six total months so you
can't even do that in six months you
have to stare at it and when you're
staring at it a counter is clocking off
like you stared at it one second then
two second and three second and then you
have to wait for that to wind down and
every time you look away the clock ain't
go take no more so how all of you losers
waste years of your life staring at that
because you're only awake for two-thirds
of the day anyway so it'd take you like
a long time ha gotcha rid the world of
depression permanently but the person
you love most will lose their memory of
you Oh
I mean I that's kind of like the benefit
of everybody
I mean rid the world of depression
permanently that that helps a lot of
people like a lot of people a lot of
people a lot of people hey they only
lose their memory of me if they love me
then it'll be like a romantic comedy
movie I'll just win them back yeah and
is not like I'm gonna be depressed about
it afterwards so I guess I'll just be
happy and I'll just go on I'll ask them
out on a date
I'll ask him out I'll show them the
pictures of us and be like you had
amnesia we were lovers
so I'm that's the worst way to tell
anybody that thing but just imagine that
I said that more smoothly and then we
went on a date so I'll press that button
yeah that's fine oh come on now 47% of
people booed you have the ability to
attract any person in the world but you
end up attracting many strange ugly and
dangerous people as well I mean just
because you attract them doesn't mean
that you have to do anything about I
mean dangerous people that's a bit
ambiguous there what kind of danger are
we talking about here people that like
to live on the edge of danger
people that like danger adrenaline
junkies or like dictators Kim jong-un is
he gonna be knocking on my door
anytime soon fine I'll present yeah sure
oh I'm in the barely minority here I
mean just cuz they're strange ugly and
dangerous doesn't mean that your life
ain't gonna be fun I mean if the
dangerous people are attracted to you
they're probably not gonna hurt ya
unless they're like obsessive about it
but then hey you've got everybody else
on your side you'll just pick the people
against each other have everyone fight
over your affections it'd be beautiful
or horrifying either way it gonna be
interesting you will become the richest
most attractive person in the world but
you will receive paper cuts between each
of your toes each morning when you wake
up no loopholes
you know you can get used to anything
it's just a paper cut right I guess I
can afford to get it taken care of
anyway I'll push it I'll do it I like to
live life on the edge
oh yeah big babies who didn't push that
button the 46% yeah yeah [ __ ] you go
back to your childhood with present mind
and fix all of your mistakes and go to
school with your current knowledge but
you tremendously change your personal
future no matter what I mean I think
that's a given
isn't that what you're trying to do if
you go back to your childhood and fix
all of your mistakes inevitably you're
gonna make more mistakes like if you're
if your life changes then you're gonna
make more mistakes and chase the
butterfly effect and all that [ __ ]
but you know how about do it I'll give
that a go why not yeah didn't say it
would change in a future in a bad way
yeah Thank You coyote crows you get your
dream job but after 10 years you're
sacked and cannot get another job I mean
that's that's kind of like what I do
right now like YouTube is kind of my
dream job and I'm already five years
into it so if I get another five years
of the good stuff and then I can't do it
anymore hey that was a good life I'll
slip into like obscurity I'll fall back
into the wayside like I think I'll have
a great time here if I can get ten I
don't even think I'm gonna get 10 years
out of this I think I got another like
three in me before the internet asks me
on a some like raft in the middle of the
ocean and then I'm just fending for
myself on some perk out reality show
when's there gonna be a reality show
about washed-up youtubers I want to be
first in line to that thing because I'm
pretty sure I will have to be first in
line for that I'll push that button yeah
give me that what's really the majority
would not press that button ten years is
a long time to do something you love for
ten years that's not like you still
couldn't do it as a hobby boom you can
talk to dead people but you will be
haunted by their dead body and nobody
else can see them are you are you only
haunted by the dead body when you're
talking to that one and what do you mean
haunted by their dead body
just like their dead body is strewn
about your house it's not even saying
like you're haunted by their ghost
you're literally honored by their dead
body I mean I guess that's bad if you
wake up one morning and roll over and
like oh god damn it
Thomas Jefferson get the [ __ ] out of my
bed oh wait you're dead I can't I talked
to the turnover and talk to their ghost
hey get your corpse out of my bed
you an Abe Lincoln I'm sick of your
pranks you sacks of [ __ ] yeah that's
probably what it is I'll do that that
sounds fun we get to hang with people
you don't have to sleep eat breathe
anymore they are optional you can live
without them
but you get horrible weekly periods if
you're a girl cannot masturbate if
you're a guy well I mean I guess that
problem solved if you get laid if you're
a guy which I am and girl doesn't apply
to me so I guess that's no good god I
would love to not have to sleep ah
but man if I didn't have to eat like
what does that mean for like working out
and stuff do i its wither or would do I
I mean I guess I could you know it
doesn't say you yeah you're optional you
can live without them so I still could
if I wanted to yeah yeah yeah okay all
right I think I can deal with that I
think I could deal with that I could I
could do that yeah I'll take that
because how much more time I would have
in the day if I didn't have to sleep
would be amazing all right I'll do that
yeah yeah yeah I don't have to deal with
the weekly period so I'm okay it's all
good don't worry about that yeah you get
to live in an awesome free mansion oh
you get to live in an awesome mansion
for free but it's full of spooky
so basically Luigi's Mansion huh yeah I
mean spooky ghosts you can make a
fortune on a reality show you every huh
did he show in your spooky mansion you
hire a camera crew and just fall around
with your spooky ghost roommates we're
always pulling spooky pranks on you yeah
that would make a killing that'd be
awesome
I don't have to live there I don't have
to live there like that could just be my
day job I'll press that button hell yeah
oh hell yeah so anyway that's all for
will you press the button I hope you
enjoyed this spattering
of questions here I'll leave you with
this one conundrum you have all the
powers of a great white shark which I
don't know what that means in terms of
powers so I guess you get to swam good
to be a real chopper you get a whole
bunch more teeth and they constantly
fall out but you don't have to worry
about it because you have new ones
regrowing
all the time also you you're huge I
don't know what's up what are the powers
of a great white uh-huh having that
baseline just to always follow your turn
and turn and like I'd like to think if
you never have to stop moving you just
can always get those guy going slightly
faster the faster you go like I'm just
going for a jog
okay anyway so I'll leave you with this
conundrum let me know what you would
pick in the comments below and thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]